well the former chancellor sunak remains
the front-runner among fellow
conservative mps and one of those who's
throwing their weight behind him is
claire coutinho mr thanks so much for
joining us this morning um so how do you
think he did
i thought he did very well to be honest
i mean he had one of the hardest
messages that he was saying to people he
wanted to be very honest about what was
happening in the economy uh but really i
think that rishi cenak was the person
who looked like he was the one who could
be prime minister in a few weeks he had
an incredibly impressive command of the
detail he also i thought had a clear
plan for the future and particularly to
deal with inflation which i think is our
number one problem at the moment and
most importantly i think he was the one
who wanted to be honest with people and
say these are the challenges are ahead
and this is what we need to do to fix
them
why couldn't he answer the question it
was a yes or no question about boris
johnson's honesty well i think he did
answer that question he said that when
he resigned honesty and trust was part
of that um and i think you know the
truth is that for all mps we will feel
that you know boris johnson for a lot of
people was the person who delivered
brexit i think for a lot of people in
the country that was a
ability to deliver something that was
part of their connection to him and
obviously in the last few months there
have been
other challenges and things which have
happened which meant have meant other
people have felt that he he's not honest
so it's not i think very easy to have
black and white answers to these um
questions but the truth is a number of
people resigned from government last
week and rishi net was one of them but
he couldn't say boris johnson was honest
so do you think
he's honest
about that and
why couldn't he just say no to that
question if that's what he thinks well i
think he was very honest about that he
talked about the fact that he resigned i
think
resigning was a principled position he
set out exactly why he did that in his
letter and as
i've explained and rishi has said in
this campaign i don't think anyone
should completely denigrate what boris
johnson has done over the last couple of
years uh he did deliver brexit um he did
very well with the things like the the
vaccine roll out
i don't think it's right to completely
trash someone's reputation but at the
same time when honesty and trust and
politics had become a challenge he did
take that difficult decision and he did
resign and actually one of the central
tenets of his campaign at the moment is
to restore trust
so
as you're saying his pitch is clearly
about being honest about the challenges
right that we face but do you think he
needs something a bit more optimistic to
win with the members don't they want
some a big britain idea or big britain
ideas to really resonate with the
members
well i mean firstly i don't
think that the members are that
different from the british public i
think what people want is a politician
who will tell them the facts as they are
and who also has
a realistic plan to deal with the
challenges that are ahead i don't think
anyone that i speak to and i speak to
lots of my constituents all of the time
is thinking that this isn't a difficult
time for the country everyone can see
what inflation is doing to their income
everyone can feel the pinch and actually
what they want is someone who can
explain to them what is happening and
what their plan is to make sure that
inflation doesn't get out of control and
that is that's exactly what rishi is
doing and to be honest i thought he was
one of the only people he was doing that
last night and i think that's why people
responded to him it wasn't the easiest
message there on that stage but he
talked about not wanting to um you know
create fairy tales he talked about
wanting to be honest about what the
situation was and actually i thought
people responded to that very well
did they did they respond to him because
his polling with members is dire
well i don't actually think that you can
look at every single poll when i've
talked to members people are very
positive about him um they see him as a
very trusted decent person
he's clearly you know very intelligent
he's got great command of detail and if
you look at some of the things that he's
done over the last couple of years
things like the furlough scheme things
like the cost of living package i think
you can see what kind of politician he
is
so you wouldn't be concerned then if who
was up against penny morden if you say
we shouldn't look at the polls well i
mean he talked last night and i agree
with this um that i think it's quite
commendable for the tory party to have
so many great candidates in the race uh
i think he'd welcome whoever he was up
against to have that debate in the final
two
um well i'm not going to get into who
should be in the final two because i
think they are all good candidates i
just think that rishi sunak is the best
candidate and i think if you uh watch
the debate last night i would urge
everyone to go and watch that debate i
think it is good that we have these
robust debates about
the economy and about the future of the
country but i thought he really did
stand out heads and shoulder as the
person who had the clearest plan and i
think that's what will come out no
matter who is the other person that he's
up against
okay claire coutinho thank you so much
for talking to us thank you